[Music]
that first five minutes you you don't
see the house until that moment where
the music kicks in so I was really moved
yeah the first time as like I said she
cried when it first came back she
decided she saw that shot like going up
to drive a royal lunch in a parade
I'm doing it I'm going to have to sit
down the fashion is something to sit in
in the film are you as fashionable as
Lady Mary cause she is me I do
I do love fashion yeah you are I'd say
you're more fashionable than Mary I
think so Michelle the audience do you
think she'd approve I think she would
she be jealous yes did you die when you
saw the clothes you know they're amazed
I mean a now I mean the costume
designers we've had over the you know
the whole series had just been we've
been very very lucky with them and Anna
is I mean she really pulled out all the
stops for the film and yeah I mean
they're stunning and the fortuny gown
that I was that I got to wear was just
incredible that blue which was very
funny because it has this sort of puddle
at the bottom and it's meant to look
like a kind of puddle on floor then of
course you can't move so I was walking
around like floating
[Music]
tell me about the first time you stepped
into Highclere Castle I mean were you
like blown away did you start snooping
it was as big as you thought it would be
I mean I feel like I took it for granted
in the early day yeah going back for the
film it really took my breath away
walking up to the castle for the first
time I turned up like the new kid in
school cuz I thought you guys were
already well into filming the first
season we might who's the new guy yeah
but it was but I was absolutely blown
away by the how so my first yeah I think
everyone knows it is it is such a
breathtaking piece of architecture and
like you said five six years ago and up
there you know six o'clock in the
morning like there's the house whatever
yeah and then going back after three
years it really does hit you and how
stunning it in yeah and every single
room has got its own personality I mean
that the library is one of my favorite
rooms in the house and we shoot a lot of
scenes in there don't worry yeah it's
it's stunning and then of course Ealing
the studios is a whole different feeling
there but that feels very much like our
home when it's you know the servants
quarters and there and the bedrooms and
but it's yeah I mean that the sets are
absolutely stunning the fan fervour for
this film just has not died down a bit
from the series team you felt that yeah
yeah what's the craziest thing that's
happened to you with a fan encounter I
mean I'm just always surprised by the
type of person that likes Downton so
often you know I'll get in a cab in
London and the cab driver will be like
you know since you know you know general
sort of hi and then and then you know
give it about a minute and then he'll be
I show him about a Matthew shame show
about Matthew Crawley we liked him yeah
you two are great couple you know this
huge burly cab driver Skynyrd's you know
so those tight it's the type of person
that really can do that I'm surprised
you and Downton and how invested they
are in the characters as well I mean
that US immigration going into the
States
I arrived and a passport control guy
took my passport look to me lifted again
went and I'd and it is sort of the
episode of just aired where I left Sybil
back in Dublin
and I had run away and he just went that
was a crappy thing you did your wife
[Laughter]
been up that ages whether they say I
don't watch it my wife watches it I just
you know I watch it in the background oh
yeah I really had a wrestling the whole
time with a my team Mary and my team
Edith yeah most of the time yeah I mean
Mary was you know especially towards the
end there
she was pretty cruel she was tough yeah
she was tough what's that what's the
weirdest thing you guys have ever seen
your face on as far as merchandising
because I know it there's a lot I'm on T
I'm gonna I'm gonna holiday I think I
think we've been on Christians haven't
we
this is Pat Moore gets a lot of snow
because you guys tea towels oh yeah
wooden spoon they're cooking yeah I've
got mrs. Patmore spoon I got here before
I leave because I need one we should
organize it fun with a tattoo of mrs.
Hughes's keys no yeah Maggie Maggie
Smith space it's got to be amazing seems
rather waste of money
oh here we go why do we love Dame Maggie
Smith so darn much she has advertised
please tell me she she's better she's
better yeah she really is and so funny
I mean she's as funny as you know those
one-liners well you have enough cliches
to get you through the visit so quick
yeah I do want to ask you find love
again
thank you I you left me with questions
oh good you did too because now I feel
like you're the heir apparent and I need
to see Downton under your control
I need another movie and then possibly
Bronson can come visit from where he
might be
yeah
[Music]
everyone do the looks yeah could you
guys be in for another yeah I absolutely
would tip I think we all would
you just gotta go talk to the notorious
ma g GI yeah you know me guys you got to
do it somebody start working on a right
now okay let's start to like on the
carpet by the way here you're married
how you doing great yes yes we're about
fantastic yeah yes okay she's here so
she's very excited for this evening as
well and you're about to work with
Captain America I just did actually oh
it's just finished as what does that
hold spear is great yeah actually we're
not quite finished but um yeah it was
great fantastic yeah we had a we had a
lot of fun even though the the content
is very intense you know with their
child on trial for murder it's not a
comedy murder
we had a great time yeah yeah and he's
great Chris had a really good time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]